[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
she
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys uh sorry about
uh all that issues man we was having
some technical issues why was uh hustle
wasn't but um you know we we back though
and we we
we are back i appreciate the uh the
patience i know
that uh you know i had a i had a depth
of stream for some reason it wasn't
showing the correct desktop audio side
of depth of stream but we're here man
we're here with hustle we're going to be
doing this i i hope you guys like the
new background man just something a
little bit nice to look at i got some
stuff uh that i'm in the early processes
of doing but it's going to be probably a
couple months before it's done because
artwork takes time but i'm here hustle
what's going on hustle
everything is good i like this
background man i definitely like it i
thought it was like a one time thing
when you tweeted that uh tweeted that
little video about with me you and uh
the homie big cloud y'all make sure
y'all go check out big club gaming on
youtube i thought that was a one-time
thing i like it though it's you know
it's it's green it's it it gives me real
uh halo reach vibes by the way i had the
pleasure of beating that game for the
very first time and um addict i didn't
know how dark that game was because
it was spoiler alert everybody dies
everybody
that
that droid was wild i see if halo was
like that i would have probably enjoyed
the story more but you know what i want
to get off time random stuff too man
like you'd be sitting there i don't want
to be fine and then bam they're dead
like
i know man cat went out so bad man i i
will
cause the outside of that i'm doing well
i think what that game does good what
reach does good is it shows
like look like not every spartan is r is
master chief like like mostly spartans
they ain't getting out of these these
these war zones they dying like
especially there at the very end when
you fight um
when you fight that dude uh uh
you're fighting the people on the
uh you're fighting all those elites and
stuff and he's on the little cannon
shooting down all the the aerial space
and right when you're about to jump on
the infinity at the end he just gets
that that some spar an elite comes out
of nowhere and just gets rid of that
dude
you know
it's good man because then you're you're
looking at master chief you look at you
i don't think you i don't know if you
see master chief it's been so long since
i played that but you're looking at him
and you know it's like
i got to do this like
it was it was like a super cool effect
at the end because we
uh myself contradiction and mega zx456
we played on normal and like one of the
coolest things was what up smoove one of
the coolest things was like when you get
hit for that first time it cracks your
visor and i was like
i think nick had brought it up so yeah
my visor's cracked and i'm like what you
talking about then i jump out there and
i get hit and it was like it was like a
super quick joint it was and i was the
first to die sadly but that that story
was like that i i really appreciate it
it really got me hyped for um halo
infinite and you know we have time at
the end of the podcast i played the sex
test this weekend super fun game
what's your uh what's your opinions
about it
uh it's bringing me back and um i don't
like the the 4v4 i know i think you
you're the opposite i like big team
battle and stuff like that but i'm not
going live playing that 4 before with
the troubleshooters man we played like
the we played capture the flag and then
we played um tdm
and then we played what was that
stronghold i love stronghold by the way
i love the objective based ups because
it makes me feel like i'm contributing
but i play a strong stronghold i think
like three times and i don't know if you
saw my stream but i was playing with
alex in them over the weekend it's super
fun like all of it and and i'm i'm up on
halo like this is free to play
which is just another great thing it's
free to play normally free to play games
don't particularly
fare so well
they don't really fare well there's not
too many of them that do but um just to
know that this is i don't wanna say it's
on the level of fortnite but
it's it's like super fun it's like
fortnite four adults and it's super fun
for me yeah the good thing about it that
i like is
just how well it feels and i know you
guys are playing the pc or maybe only
alex was but you know i know there's
some issues on the pc but you know it is
a tech test and i'm not even saying
they're going to have these completely
ironed out before the game comes out but
it is nice to see you know
them have
the game just running great
oh yeah um i was actually playing on the
xbox one x
for the simple fact that i couldn't get
into the pc beta but on the one x it ran
well it literally it ran well enough i
mean it was true it was popping here and
there but like that's you know hallway
came out whenever this when this came
out 2016. it's 2021 so i'm i wasn't
tripping too too hard off of that and
i'll forgive it um but i will be on um i
will be on that pc i will definitely be
on that pc and for the first time or
second time ever i'll be on keyboard and
mouse so i'm going to look up some
videos on how to
bind my keys so to speak i sound like a
nerd already but i'm going to buy my
keys and i'm actually going to give it
like a fair shake because everything
felt like super good during the beta on
controller i can only imagine like from
what i'm hearing from other people like
who played on you know keyboard and
mouse they said it feels really good and
this is good to hear
one of the things that i've always
appreciated that i thought that they
could do
is i know people i've said this a couple
times is you know
story-wise it would be awesome and i
think i might have said it here but
you've finally played reach it's like
i thought it would be cool
if noble didn't die there
and the bandits captured
and it know he turns out to be like the
antagonist of of a halo game
like like atrialx brainwashed him and
then that's like the only time you ever
see like a
an antagonist being a spartan you know
what i'm saying like and i think that
would have been cool like imagine like
you chasing up something you see nothing
but like dead marines and everywhere you
get to the end of it and it's just like
noble like having like someone like a uh
us not a spartan but like a marine he
just snaps his neck and he falls and
it's just like you know imagine like the
the the after effect that you realize
this man has been alive this entire time
and he's one of the reasons that the
banish has done what he's been able to
do you know what i'm saying like
but you know that that's just like a a
crazy fan thing but but you know let's
go ahead and get on
with the show
but i you know i appreciate everyone
coming through is the attic show we talk
about the past present and future gave
me seen people in the comments section
talking i mean the chat talking about
spoilers i definitely understand your
your concept dude but
hello the game came out like 10 15 years
ago man like i can't 2010
it's in the master chief collection now
don't you dare apologize for him not
playing a game for 15 years like look
like i'll be like i usually give you a
couple years man before i start but i
mean we did say spoiler alert too so you
know it is what it is uh but you know i
definitely understand that but you know
let's get into the news man because they
it's been a very
maybe not
crazy newsweek but there's been some
effective news weeks you know what i'm
saying like we got the playstation
buys blue point which is very
interesting how that's going down uh you
know and then there i don't know if you
saw the ign game of the generation thing
did you see that it's so disrespectful
we're gonna have to talk about
we're gonna have to talk about that
because i feel like that is the craziest
thing i've ever seen in my life
but we're definitely going to talk about
that uh then we're about to talk about
the xbox game uh game pass success
let me just type we are done splint
oh my god i get it he don't want to be
in room for him and maybe some people
are playing you know halo for the first
time
er everything all would have collection
and stuff but it's just like i get it
we'll stop with that stuff man i get it
uh so we gotta find all the super trap
from the gaming forte that crispy 4k
camera looking fine sup hustle always
looking like he praying when he
listening to someone speak
that's right that's funny you know what
it is hey i got to do something with my
hands because now i don't know if i got
80d or something but i low keep like
keep moving around and stuff the reason
why i got the shades and all this
because i keep looking at the chat and i
keep looking at different stuff on the
pc and stuff that's why i would like
rock the shades too but yeah right there
i better i'll calm down a little bit i
mean let me relax listen y'all know how
it is like when you first buy like a new
home or when you first start a new job
you're a little nervous you're a little
anxious and you know the second i settle
in and i can sit back and relax and you
know me and that it can go back and
forth like you know back to back like
the cover of a lethal weapon we'd be
high we'll be all right but until then
i'm just i'm just moving around a little
bit my fault y'all my fault yeah and
it's perfectly fine man cognito likes to
talk with his hands too but all right so
i want to talk about this playstation
buys blue point thing man i want to talk
about show real quick uh
we first off
i think we all saw this coming i i think
we can all agree on that especially
don't you wouldn't you say we knew this
was coming
uh yeah it's a matter of time
my question to you hustle is why now
it's kind of a weird timing just to just
announce that you know what i'm saying
like they didn't announce it at the last
at their event
they didn't announce it before the event
but they announced the other stuff they
didn't announce it when they announced
the other um the person who made return
um
so i'm kind of curious on
why the timing to do it now
it
okay
shout out to jacqueline johnny he said
every time that playstation does
something good they always seem to do
something bad um okay i want to take you
all the way back before i answer your
question i want to see you all the way
back to when they bought house mark and
when they bought them for the first time
remember we saw that leaked uh image of
a blue point being another acquisition
and a lot of people were like okay cool
they're going to announce them both
then they'll say oh somebody made you
know then they said somebody made a
mistake i'm like nah they they took a
little time to work on that on that
photoshop i wouldn't doubt that is real
all right but let me ask you a question
though man
why didn't why they did it now
it may have been in lieu of the last of
us factions 2 not being announced on the
last of us today um i remember weapon
wheel was on
everybody was waiting with baited breath
and then then that gray screen came up
it's like hey we here we working on
fashions too but uh
we ain't ready yet we ain't ready yet
jim ryan was like no say this announcing
now announcing now so they probably just
announced it just after like that bad
news because it seemed like it probably
seemed like they were getting a little
you know
not bad pressed but just worst person
they're probably accustomed to so i was
like well we got the good news here so
hopefully this will get your mind off of
the other stuff that you're really
waiting on um
it took them long enough they finally
put a ring on it it took them forever
and
my
brief
my extremely brief history with blue
point in particular um as you know is
with the uncharted series uh i played on
try to one beat that one played
uncharted two beat that as well off the
blueprint um excuse me blue point
remakes and i'm halfway through
uncharted three
they're good but i'm praying that
playstation i know you didn't ask this
question but i'm playing i'm praying
that playstation allows them to make
their own game i feel like that's like
a wasted thing because they don't have
to do the console remakes and the pc
remakes because they got nexus on pc for
that too they don't have to do them both
man they don't have to i mean in my
personal opinion i feel like they don't
have to do them both but it would be
great for them to spread their wings you
know metaphorically
and just be able to do their own thing
but you know we'll have to see how
things go
i actually
i'm gonna push back a little bit on that
i feel like if they do that very well
why not have them continue that but i'm
gonna say i do feel like they have
justified that they deserve a shot
and at the end of the day even if they
completely dropped the ball
and they got that opportunity
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen
okay you gave you we gave you the
opportunity you didn't deliver go back
to remakes
so
i do feel like they deserve that shot
they um they made the uncharted
collection they made playstation
all-stars which i didn't know
and gravity rush which i haven't played
yet but gravity rush looks amazing that
they made that and apparently from what
i'm looking at on the site they made
titanfall that had something to do with
that
i had no clue
i i literally had no clue and then they
did uh eco and uh shadow of the colossus
oh and if everybody has a ps5 in the
chat you can actually play shadow of the
colossus for free as a part of the
playstation well not free but the
playstation
uh the playstation collection pack i
think that's what it's called but um
they got that they got god of war they
have uncharted 4. they have all all of
those like classic titles persona 5 as
well and you can actually play that for
free so if you haven't played anything
the 360 version all right thank you
smoove i appreciate that um so if you
haven't played anything in reference to
blue point um oh wait if you haven't
played anything reference the blue point
the first thing i'm gonna recommend to
you uncharted play down on charter
collection um play uncharted two on
charter one didn't age but so well but i
guess given you know given how old that
game actually was you know blue point
did they think there's a couple hiccups
here and there but blue point did their
thing and then this is this is good for
them
you know addict i i kind of want to ask
you this question
oh why not microsoft
do you like a point
yeah because i mean because you know i
think i heard phil spencer say once upon
a time that
when something goes up for sale like we
know about it
so like how like i guess my question is
how big would the bag have to be in
order for that acquisition to happen how
bad do you think it would have to be for
that acquisition to happen
definitely more than what sony paid
because you're asking them to go off
something that they're comfortable with
i don't know though like
i think that's not something that
they're interested in
i think they're more interested in you
know innovating newer ips or you know i
mean i guess you can't really say that
because perfect dart
but i don't know if they want you that
only does that and for the most part
that's all they're really known for is
is remaking stuff
so you know i'm kind of curious
are they going to let them fully make
their own game
because to me
this is the only thing we know of them
doing
so i'm curious that they're going to let
them
it's
it's okay all right and i just want to
speak i'm not a game developer obviously
but i am i am a creative like i'm an
extremely creative person like
if i do the same thing for too long
right
then i become stagnant uh you know i get
a little upset with myself and they
don't make me stop wanting to do it i i
hope that blue point doesn't have like
that same mentality because i think what
they would do would surprise us all
like like um what house mark did right
like like a return i feel like if they
got the if they got the bread behind
more pardon me if they got the budget
behind them right
then i feel like you know the sky's the
limit with that just the sky's the limit
because they've even with the remakes
i'm just looking at them now they've
made a variety of so many different
games it would be great for them to just
like do their own thing and i i guess
i'm just waiting to see what it is you
know if it's good it's good and like you
said earlier if it's not so good i mean
they they kind of earned like the pass
they kind of earned that pass to be like
all right well this didn't work and
we'll go back to what we're doing but
i just felt like they've earned it um at
this point and honestly i think mbg has
said it um one of those
i think was when
bethesda or that zenimax still happened
on microsoft and people saw my blue
point
i wouldn't just pay a studio just to
remake
older stuff they they're good at what
they do but at the same time man you can
make another horizon zero done
you could um i'm saying like all of
those new ips that they have like
kenneth is apparently it's gonna be
something big i'm not gonna speak too
much on canada but like that could like
be another sleeping here because i'm
only like an hour you know on it but
that could be like another thing and
they could have yet another character to
the arsenal like a part of that roster
part of that starting five so to speak
i think the reasons that they're going
to stay away from stuff like that is
because
sony has a lot of stuff they can do i
feel like bluepoint is a studio that can
make quality products in a sufficient
amount of time with not a huge huge
budget
and i think they value that more than
value having a new ip
because they got plenty of studios
making something new uh that they can
make something new
and you know if you're gonna
fund a huge project why don't you just
have like naughty dog or sucker punch do
it you know what i'm saying like
it's like i feel like they bought blue
point because blue point does what they
do well i think they might give them the
opportunity and you know if they came
out and knock it out of the park they
might keep continue getting that
opportunity but we got to see what they
do with their own game before you know
we can really say that they deserve the
kind of budget someone like naughty dog
gets
oh yeah well well you know naughty dog
they're not in the league all they all i
wonder how much they brought them for
you remember with the insomniac deal um
they reported it on
it was 229 million um reported by cnet
and i i kind of wanted to look that up
as we were talking just to see but i
don't i don't think we've heard anything
in reference to that so question i have
for you is what do you think they would
make
well
you mean what remake they would make
yeah if if they were to remake something
what is the three games that you would
like for them to remake
i'm going to take an answer from the
chat from mr po i can't pronounce your
first name uh sir but he said silent
hill silent hill seems like the obvious
choice because everybody thinks abandon
is silent hill um
it wouldn't be anything crash brandon
kooks that's activision or it wouldn't
be spyro
it wouldn't be the game with the
skeleton um on it because that just came
out
it's
you know what i and i know this is being
worked on i'm gonna say it anyway last
of us part one i'm saying anyway last of
us problem we know that's being worked
on but like now that you have blue point
i feel like you can give that to them
and then have them
do their thing at that point
uh
let's see jack and dexter is another one
hey shout out to uh
oh wait a minute let me get your name
right sir
a dogo with a cool
yo a dogo with a cool smartphone good
name sir
very good name um
i you know i can't i can't say for sure
because like the the first ips that come
to my mind like all the ones that i've
already played and i know what the
remakes that we've already got um
i can't
i would see all right i would love to
say the order 1886 but that kind of just
came out and that game already looks
phenomenal but if that can you imagine
like a remaster of that like they the
order like that's
that's my b that's right there yes sir
bloodborne i feel like oh no
i feel like that the company that they
need to do is is
is legends of dragoon
i feel like they need to do something
like that but the thing is like sequel
nor remake
the question
is
are can they make something like legend
or dragoon
in this current
you know this current space that we're
in like because like to me
i'm kind of curious on the fact that
look what they had to do with final
fantasy vii look how much like it took
to bring that to another generation
to another audience
i felt like you would have to do
something similar with legendary legend
of dragoon so i don't think they would
do something like that you know i i
don't think
legend of dragoon would take a lot of
money to bring back
um splendiferous in the chat he says uh
what about siphon filter
um
i'll be honest with you are y'all sure
y'all will want a remake of that
it's just
because it always seemed like a low
budget uh gold in that of me like i
briefly played it i didn't
i didn't like and that's a goal now a
low budget the world is not enough
that's that's kind of what it felt like
it just didn't it didn't feel right to
me i mean
blue point you know they can't work
magic like i said they did it with
uncharted 1 which like i said again
which is a fun game but just didn't age
well um
yeah that could be one that could be one
i mean it is what it is regardless what
they work on uh
you know
sony bought them for it so if they get a
new ip i think they do deserve it and if
they make
you know remakes
that's fine too
let's go ahead and uh
one last thing before we go shout out to
eric the beard in the chat um he said
dino crisis now i've seen a few people
in our community who have kind of been
clamoring for that as well um
i don't know i i never played down on
crisis i can't i can't say i'm neither
here nor there but uh that that i feel
like that would be a good like revival
it probably needs to happen to be honest
with you
dino crisis
i don't know
like weren't they supposed to be working
on a metal gear solid or something like
that like
i'm not sure you but i do see blue point
did metal get solid one and two though i
see they did the remakes for that as
well
i mean now i'm not the biggest uh coach
of my fan as you know
but it you know
the uh the cowboys at capcom won't do it
now capcom ain't gonna do it the money
ain't there y'all sorry the money ain't
dead if the money
if if the if the demand isn't there then
you know they're not gonna do that
they're not gonna win stay town
wild arms that
look man regardless what they do
i i am very curious to see how it goes
a game of the
generation but we're gonna go ahead and
move on to the ign game of the
generation
uh because uh it started a lot of stuff
last year uh last week man like did you
catch any of it
um i
i caught bits and pieces of it i kind of
wasn't keeping up with it i saw like
because other websites were doing this
too um one of the websites i follow on
instagram they had these whole versus
badass things going on
um i'm looking at the the link that you
sent me man and
like all right if you're gonna put one
game against another you have to put if
you're gonna put grand theft auto
against
like another open world game then i
understand like grand theft auto versus
saints row like okay that i understand
like they had like super mario world
versus hold on let me make sure i get
this right man it was so it was it
wasn't like even it wasn't even
whatsoever and i'm let me zoom in there
super mario world versus super smash
brothers like
the audacity
the real audacity man
i don't know who like it makes me wonder
like
what's there like
like who's voting on on this like what's
the what's the age demographic because i
would really love to know because
anybody like my age or hell even your
age addict they're not voting super
smash brothers before super mario world
super mario world as you know is an
all-time classic like one of the
greatest games of all time point blank
per year and i'm not no nintendo dude
but
i i don't know
i'm
i
i feel physically ill i'm thoroughly
disgusted to be completely honest with
you at the whole the whole shebang all
right look i understand why they did it
they got the conversation going but
we're going to be real man we can't take
this little serious respect and i said
that respectfully the people who work it
out jin i i can't man because they don't
even have it like correct like that's
like
me making the comparison just like you
comparing me to another like a sneaker
youtuber won't even do the same thing
it's not even the same
yeah it is ridiculous let's let's go
over a little bit of these
now let me
disable our camera so i can bring it
over
pretty successfully
all right so now
let me make this a little bit larger
here hold on f11 there we go so this is
what me and hustler talking about now
you guys gotta uh keep in mind if i i'm
being a little bit
you know
quite i'm not trying like i don't know
why but everyone the moment we went live
man my mouth started hurting
uh so oh no
yeah i don't know what happened like
it's it's definitely
been a little painful man but we'll get
through this all right so this is the
bracket
this is like the craziest stuff i've
ever seen
so is there uh anything on this bracket
that you want to talk about in
particular
you can afford to come up on the screen
this is this is the one with um god of
war being the winner right
okay hold on pull this back up
all right let's take a look let's take a
look hold on f11
bow all right
let me minimize that
all right y'all okay so the first thing
that i do want to talk about
uh grand theft auto san andreas on the
left-hand side grand theft auto san
andreas versus mario kart y'all remember
what i was telling y'all before about
this ain't even the same like it's
almost not even fair because mario kart
mario kart 8 from the little bit that i
played over rarity too
yeah it's a really good game no granted
they made the right choice but it's like
oh put put an open word that that game
should have went against borderlands
grand theft auto san andreas it should
have went against like like i get it i
get they needed like this like fallout
would have been a better like competitor
like i don't i don't get it man
this one here's where i officially was
done
is when
burnout 3 beat chrono trigger
i didn't even see this yeah
like that
is crazy
chrono trigger um ladies and gentlemen
or maybe for the younger audience who
might not be super familiar i believe
the same artist that drew um that made
that and they made they made the
characters on there he did a dragon ball
z as well
and chrono trigger again shout out to
contradiction that's her favorite game
of all time that is a an extremely
classic rpg for the super nintendo man
if you haven't played it try to try to
get your hands on a snes classic emulate
it what have you that's one of those
ones with
those that's one of those ones that you
definitely should play if you haven't
played it all right so someone said
go ahead and put in games in the chat
and i'll see if they're on this list
we'll do this for a couple minutes
someone said
resident evil 4. i think that that has
to be on here somewhere
okay arena time got robbed it did and i
actually thought it imma be real with
you i really thought that that one would
have just taken it i thought that that
one because that's another one man
went against castlevania sympathy of the
night
that's actually that's a good good
comparison
that's on the left-hand side of the
right hand side it's on the right it's
at the bottom before the right
oh okay i see it all right number 10
number seven
super mario brothers 3 versus persona 5
right yes i i saw
at
i was at work
when you sent me the information when i
saw that
i was like come on dog
now of course super mario that super
mario 3 isn't my number four top four
top five games all the time i said that
on the iron laws episode 165 for those
you all who are wondering
yeah
um
but it's that's not right man it's not
it's not an rpg
like come on man like come on like
that's something that got to be like
they got to fix that because look at
this it's so
technical
it's rock band
now where is that sir it's on the right
on the right side
a little bit of
uh resident evil 4.
i mean
let me find it yeah tetris versus rock
band
yeah now i expect tetris to win that
because it's all classic
now
half-life of vr game versus bloodborne
why why wait why was that even there
like if it was the original half-life
then i get it because i kind of changed
first-person shooters from what i
understand like that i understand
why would that won't be there is that
well okay uh eddie do you have vr
no
okay i was gonna say if it's really that
good then then i get it but
you know
it's only on steam via or it's only on
as forms of vr
um
super super metroid they did super
metroid so dirty man super metroid went
up against apex legends come on man who
was voting on this super metroid almost
won it shouldn't have lost i'm gonna be
real with you it shouldn't have lost
there's a reason why people say
metroid vedio they came from super
metroid the very it came from super
metroid if i came from metro yes super
mario 64 versus batman arkham city it's
somehow batman arkham city won that
disrespect that that one particular is
because
a lot of these games wouldn't exist
without that super mario 64.
it it literally revolutionized 3d gaming
like
like like super mario did on the
nintendo
super mario 64 revolution everybody made
their game at the super mario 64. now
and oh solely three especially 3d
platforms and i don't want to hear
otherwise because you you see that
influence in a bunch of different games
anyway
it's
i don't know what this is to make my
stomach hurt man like i don't like it i
don't like it man and
they had street fighter 2
street fighter 2 versus pokemon yellow
like why
oh that one would have hurt cognito halo
2 versus mass effect 2.
okay well halo well they made the right
decision on that but i'm not gonna lie
they
they kind of did even though you know
what i can't even say that for sure
right because you remember with halo 2
in particular that game ended
prematurely it ended
you know sooner do the time constraints
before it really should have
um
like it hi man i'm
i'm i'm thoroughly disgusted my favorite
game of all time on uncharted 2 among
thieves went up against grand theft auto
5. why
why would you do that like
for me it's gonna be
i'm happy that fallout new vegas made it
so far made it to like the semifinals
yeah that's only your left hand
i don't know if i should ask you that
publicly i was going to ask you how old
you were when um san andreas came out
but
i remember well for 13 or something like
that yeah yeah when that game came out
uh i was graduating high school that
year as a matter of fact but i remember
when that game came out
like i remember like the mass hysteria
it was like halo 3 and i wasn't even in
the gaming community like that like
what's up
let's go ahead and just focus on the
winners so god of war faced starcraft
this is gotta work clearly won that then
god of war faced portal 2.
god of war clearly won that
then god of award face elder scrolls
skyrim
i'm gonna be real with you skyrocketed
took that one
are you sure
okay so you have to speak to more and
more to uh
skyrim than me mix i've never played one
but i have
played about three and a half if not
four hours in god of war 2018 which is
the winner um i'll be real with you like
i said they're not even like they're not
even and that's not even the same fight
and it's kind of kind of unfair
but from what i've experienced playing
god of war 2018 just you know
graphically i'm gonna leave the graphics
out of it because this game came out
much later but
just in terms of storytelling is there
something
do you think a better story could be
told
with these competitors i guess that's my
first question
i don't know
i think a lot the reason a lot of these
games didn't really do anything it's
just because they've been out of the
media for so long
like this you know this
thing was done in
2013-14 skyrim probably would have won
but then god of war didn't even come out
like you know you got down here
minecraft versus the witcher and the
witcher won that and then it was god of
war versus the witcher and i personally
feel like the witcher is a better game
than god of war and i don't even like
the witcher like that it's just you
could tell you know what i'm saying
so let's go over here to yeah
all right grant the thought of five
versus uncharted two
well you know how i feel about it when i
was on iron laws podcast grand theft
auto 5 was my number five
it has been dethroned um uncharted 2 is
my number one for a reason man um
everything doesn't have to be open world
but i get it this is rockstar when they
do open world they do it right so trust
me i 1000 understand like why this game
is so highly coveted for me though
and just for me like i like the goofy
i'm gonna say goofy but i like the
light-hearted like fun now grand theft
auto 5 offers you that as well right
but i feel like uncharted 2 just told a
much better story than grand theft auto
5. and i love
i love grand theft auto i love both of
those games but uncharted 2 for me and
that game came out back in 2009 i do
believe and i feel like it was just a
better story that was told
i actually
when it comes to this
i
i think i think
the right one won
to be honest with you like
i i get uncharted 2's the goat into a
lot of people's eyes but like gta 5 is a
phenomenon you know what i'm saying like
i don't think there'll ever be another
game quite like gta 5.
yeah and i think that's the reason why
um rockstar is good to put out gta 6 to
be completely honest with you because
that that is a lot to live up to it's
definitely the second best grand theft
auto um grand theft auto game period
number one for me grand theft auto 4 and
i know people may not agree with that
but you know and i'll keep that answer
short because i see that you're in a
little bit of pain over there i'll keep
that answer short though grand theft
auto 4 is is probably the best story not
even see that game more here
now halo 2 versus gta 5.
gta 5 for me
that's so much easier
that's so much easier
here's a hard one for you last of us
versus gta5
last of us
um i'll be honest with you the last of
us got robbed
the story in the last of us as y'all
know definitely one of my favorite
stories of all time
it's better than grand theft auto now
granted i know i like the goofy tones
and and stuff like that
and the last of us you know and i'll
read i'm going to repost those streams
at a point
that game brought out a wide variety of
emotions in myself that i didn't think a
game could actually do so so the last of
us is always gonna have a special place
in my heart but uh just story alone i
like i like the last of us um gameplay
alone as well um with the stealth
elements that are there and i don't even
like stealth games for the record i
don't like them but i enjoy them here so
i mean you know it's just
it meant the whole lot and they had a
lot of moments that that made you laugh
had a couple moments that made me cry in
particular
the last of us got robbed man
they got robbed and then gta 5 versus
batman arkham city
oh we're putting gta 5 over there
then gta 5 versus uh
versus legend of zelda breath of the
wild
i won't support nintendo over here like
that so we definitely put in grand theft
auto 5 overhead for the record y'all
full disclosure i never played a breath
of the wild but from what i understand
it's kind of like the witcher 3 they had
elements from different games and good
for nintendo on that but i'm good i'm
good on that i think god of war versus
gta 5.
should have been gta 5 i'll be honest
with you it should have been
it one thousand percent should have been
grand theft auto five i'll be real with
you this is more about popularity than
anything i don't agree with the majority
of this i feel like it's just because
people are playing it now not
necessarily what was a better game but i
digress i'm not gonna really argue with
people's opinions uh doing stuff by
popularity you'll get stuff like this a
lot
so
i apologize to people man um
i think
i i'm in a lot of pain man i think i'm
just gonna end it i'm sorry hustle i
don't know why you just started i gotta
i gotta end the podcast or
we'll talk a little bit briefly about um
about this game pass so they finally hit
30 million man how did you feel about
that
well
let's guess
let's let's be honest it's not them hit
30 million
they it looks like they might have hit
30 million
it is definitely speculated between 18
million is what they last announced and
what the gentleman from i think that was
take two who who announced it
i'll say this
i'm not going to completely call bs on
it
he definitely knows something that we
don't and i like i said and i see his
hearing a lot of pain know things i'm
looking at you now
i'll make this quick if it isn't 30
million it's probably on the verge of it
and my thing is knowing phil spence and
no no an xbox in particular they're
probably going to make a huge
announcement about this and it's
probably going to roll out into
something else after they make that huge
announcement like hey we sold 30 million
and guess what grand theft auto 5 is
back or nba 2k or
whatever in reference to 2k since he
kind of spilled the beans on that a
little bit
yeah i think
that's what it really may have had to be
is it was a i jumped a gun too soon
we have a place where we want to say
this why'd you do that i know king
wanted to go on and on about the
that about him saying we
and to some point
it is weird that he said we
but i think maybe he was just talking
from a you know a friendly thing you
know we're at this we're at that i don't
necessarily mean he was thinking that
you know we bought that company i think
it's good i i think that you know a lot
of people come at me because i say you
know microsoft needs to do more in the
japanese stuff
but at the end of the day
there's a reason that i feel like they
need to do that they need to be as
diverse as possible and have their hands
as many as in many cookie jars as
possible to get more of the audience
there as possible and i think unless you
improve in all areas
game pass is going to have a not a short
ceiling but it's going to have a shorter
selling than it could have if you appeal
to a way more audience and i think right
now sure they do get certain things in
the audience but they need
they need more in there
and i think eventually they are going to
do it and we're at seeing the beginning
stages of it and i'm hoping that you
know they they really take that
seriously going forward
oh indeed indeed i think um
this may be the beginning
beginning of a beautiful relationship
between those two i don't think um i
don't think microsoft is going to buy
take two i think that i know they got we
know they got the money for but we
definitely don't see that type of
acquisition but they'll probably be
working closer together um remember back
in the day um they had that deal with a
grand theft auto 4 and they had the
exclusive to the xbox 360 first
so i wouldn't be surprised if we saw
that type of thing happening
in terms of hey we got grand theft auto
6 first here
maybe in game pass and i think that
it'll take a lot of money for that to
happen but i think we see that first
it's not a pixel says that um
jrpgs aren't relevant it's not about
being relevant or anything like that
it's it's about being as diverse as
possible and being open to as many
consumers as possible
uh and you know they need to do better
on that
but you know
as far as
the 30 million if they have that then
that's cool you know
it's nice to see the subscription
service grow
we're going to probably see more come
from that because you know obviously if
they're meeting their quotas they're
going to invest more money into it to
make to meet better quotas but you know
is there any kind of like you know
thought process you saw when you saw
this
well the first thing that ran through my
mind when i heard the 30 million number
was like okay well he's obviously privy
to information that we aren't
and if he's going on about those numbers
then they definitely see something
that they want they want to put most of
their games in their game pass because
as we know the game players you need a
lot of you need a ton of games over
there in order to keep that service
afloat up until the new stuff comes out
guys it's just uh just one of those
things uh like i said it's probably it's
going to lead i got a feeling it's going
to lead to some type of third party deal
i mean i can't say whether it's grand
theft auto 6 or the next 2k what have
you but
it'll probably be like and then when i
say deal i mean like a marketing deal
it'll probably lead to some type of
marketing deal like hey play it play it
best on xbox or something like that you
know how they do
yeah
well let's see i i do think we'll see
some more third party stuff coming there
day and date but i do think once these
first party studios start to really get
the stuff out there i think they'll
start to tune down on that a little bit
and rely maybe one or two of those a
year
indies and their first party titles and
obviously bringing stuff that's been out
for six months to a year they're going
to continue doing that as well
but it's good man let's see more see how
long it takes how do you think how long
do you think it would take for them to
get to 50 million
so i'll give it three years if
and i say that given we have to see
perfect dark we have to see a lot of
their first party titles we had to see
whatever bethesda's working on we got to
see the new star field we got to see all
that but i would say i give about
halfway through this generation well
from this point about three more years
and i think that they can definitely hit
that magical 50 million number because
you know now granted they don't need
they don't need to sell 50 million
consoles
all that stuff can be available on your
ogx box through the cloud and all that
too so i think that they can hit it um
in about three years from now assuming
that you know all the games hit
i definitely agree with you so you know
like i said you guys i uh you know i'm
gonna go and end the show uh i apologize
for such a short show man i was fine
until about three or four minutes into
the show it's so you know i took an
ibuprofen it's it's just not doing
nothing um i appreciate it for coming
through you know uh usually i'd like to
keep these to an hour and a half
probably only been an hour show i
appreciate hustle for coming on man i
i'ma take something to go to bed i don't
know what the hell is going on
but uh i appreciate it for coming
through and we'll see you next week like
i said i apologize for such a a a short
show i went through all the trouble to
make sure everything looked nice but um
i ain't gonna make it another 10 15
minutes i'm just gonna be real with you
guys i appreciate it talk to you guys
later
go ahead and say say something hustle oh
hey uh i'm still yeah that's so good
outro yeah yeah hey it's all good
your health is way more important than
this hey we'll see y'all next week um
ain't nothing going on with me this week
you'll see me around you'll just see me
around but
i will see y'all next week